[Music]
you your brothers Chris and Luke all
actors yeah you're all actors which is
the best which is the best well I don't
want to say it but I'd probably go with
me yeah that's the correct answer
actually you're here they're not
organized right I have a lot of brothers
so that I would do the same thing
how many brothers you go I'm one of six
really I'm one of six kids and I've got
they are they all as big as you
yeah they're all big guys I got there
are four of us good and we were like a
street gang a really unintimidating we
best way we went around town asking
people trivia questions yeah out of a
fight yeah exactly how about you what
you and you and your brothers are a lot
of we you yeah well you a street gang
were you close that way we were yeah my
brothers are my best friends you know I
wouldn't be be doing this job I think if
it wasn't for them and my oldest brother
Luke got into acting first and he did TV
shows for a long time in Australia and I
mean Chris got into it and that was kind
of how I got into it that's cool it's a
it's become a family business which is
great yeah a little bit you did I want
to ask you
we're gonna get onto paranoia in a
second but you did The Expendables 2
since since I last saw you did yeah and
you worked with jean-claude Van Damme
jean-claude Van Damme yeah I'm just
curious like what's that experience you
actually had fight scenes with
jean-claude Van Damme all right yeah
don't cry right now that's how you have
to say his name either way that's how we
say yeah you can say everyone else's and
then you get to his it's like he's he's
just he's a scary person
nice guy to work with but a scary person
a scary way just man being Van Damme and
you know he not sure if he's gonna have
a conversation or just kick your face in
he's like that
no he's a really nice guy I would talk
bad about him cuz he might kill me yeah
took care of it but yeah y-you can't ya
know he's a good guy though we had a
scene where he he he kicks me in the
chest and he wasn't supposed to really
hit me in the chest and he we did a take
and he did a full Van Damme kick and it
hit me right in the chest and after the
take rocks ever came over it's like you
okay and I said yeah I'm good I'm um you
know no worries and and then he came up
he said it's okay it's a controlled kick
so it's not that controlled because you
hit me really hard yeah you kicked me
full in the chest but it was it was I
felt it was an honor to receive back
kick
I think if you're gonna get kicked by
someone Van Damme is probably a good
person to get kicked by that's just so
funny that like yeah he can it's it's
not his place to say that you're okay
but I'm noticing it up to him to go like
he's fine it's okay